what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John here today we are going to
watch the new rock stars Easter egg breakdown
for black panther wakana forever we've just
finished a little more than a three hour live
stream talking about wakana forever now I got
it ourselves 40 minutes of Eric Voss to tell
us everything we didn't talk about guys uh
leave a like follow new rock stars and you can
check out that live stream let's get into it
[Music]
rockstars I'm and this is a breakdown
of black panther what kind of forever a
film that teaches us how in grief there is
power in a truly remarkable feat of Cinema
to advance the thematically rich thought
experiment of wakanda somehow without its
beloved hero t'challa the late Chadwick
Boseman we must dive deep into this film
to celebrate how director Ryan coogler
pulled this off breaking it down scene
by scene not just for the marble Easter eggs
really for what I consider to be even more
rewarding and easier to overlook filmmaking
choices spoilers what who cares about those
please allow me to heal my brother now of course
boss is a panther deity of wakanda the entity that
endows the Black Panther with their powers she
prays because she needs to regrow the heart-shaped
herb all of which was burned by killmonger in
the 2018 film and boss is believed to be the
spiritual source of that herb sure he scrambles
in her lab to heal t'challa by regrowing this herb
synthetically with her AI griot voiced by Trevor
Noah oh what I had no idea the whole time and it's
funny Andrew commented to me yesterday that the
credits moved so fast and I yeah I totally didn't
catch it and would never have uh realized this
oh my God that's so cool what it's a gripping
90-second long take no cutting documentary style
underscoring this is a true medical emergency
now the Herb's DNA is shown in a double helix
configuration with white orbs while the 2018 film
opened with grains of black this is orbs of white
already cast in the wakandan color of mourning
reports of the DNA points says good enough and
orders it 3D printed but her mother Ramona enters
to report your brother is with the ancestors now
t'challa's illness is never specified in his film
out of respect to the late Chadwick Boseman whose
death in August 2020 after a private battle with
colon cancer prompted a rewrite of the script
this way Ryan coogler and co-writer Joe Robert
Cole avoid exploiting Bozeman's death as a plot
point or a spectacle piece it's not really about
how t'challa died it's about how to mourn and
so by using simply the word illness Cosmic MCU
battle but really a more grounded way that many
of us have lost our loved ones and truly the way
that we lost Chadwick sure is our focal character
for this story and this movie evolves her is comic
relief Kid Sister to a true instrument of grief
who through her journey teaches us how to heal
ourselves because while she's really trying to
heal her brother in the opening minutes her true
mission of this film is to heal herself like the
proverb physician heal thyself shuri's wounds will
only be treated when she takes the remedy that
she's trying to produce for her brother and once
she properly Grieves her lost family Bost answers
her prayers with t'challa's Legacy okay see that's
part of why I find this movie so beautiful is
because like what Eric wanted it out too is that
it's more than just mourning the loss of Chadwick
Boseman there is a catharsis to be had for as most
of us I've imagined most of us have lost someone
in our lives in a lot of ways you know this is
that catharsis like for me it's been a been a
few years since I've really lost someone that
was impactful and instrumental in my development
however I would say that there is something a
bit of a true connection that feels heard and
listened to when I watch something like this and I
think that's why it hits me so strong t'challa is
buried in a private family plot as water is poured
in soil hydrating this plot we're sure we'll
later plant future heart-shaped herbs shapeway
the shaman successor to spiritual Elder Zuri in
the 2018 film in Terrace t'challa as the son of
t'chaka in the descendant of bashenga the first
black panther and while it's all in wakandan the
term black panther is in English suggesting that
like Namor this is a name given to the hero by The
Outsiders of this world while t'challa himself is
buried here is paraded through the streets of the
golden sea of wakanda a festive celebration of
life shuri Ramona and all the wakandans wear the
color white as they did while they were mourning
to Chaka in the 2018 film we passed a naval guard
playing a water drum which is a cameo by Jabari
Exum a drumming and movement coach from the 2018
film and a friend of Chadwick boseman's whom
Lupita nyongo said would drum while they did
their fight training or this movie oh that's so
cool part of their Rhythm one way now trying to
keep Chadwick's Spirit fighting alongside them in
this movie a tribute billboard oh that's beautiful
translates to the panther king forever lives in us
and rests with the ancestors overhead wakanda Jets
crisscross in a flyover leaving like the wakandan
chest salute the Royal Cemetery gate is flanked by
statues of bashenga on one side and a female on
the other both of whom have Panther statues at
their feet the female could be bashanka's wife
or her sister either way both t'challa's sister
and his wife play key roles in Burger in his
legacy as they salute his good symbolism music
is ludwigsen's ancestral plain theme to me the
most powerful Melody from his oscar-winning score
it's the music t'challa heard when he entered the
ancestral plane to join his ancestors in the 2018
film and it's the music he and we here now and
then under reverence silence the Marvel Studios
Fanfare replaces typical imagery of Avengers with
moments and Script quotes from Chadwick Postman
s t'challa first the script quote in Civil War
when he told Natasha about the green field with
Boston segment after his father died then our
very first shot of Chadwick in the MCU when he
looked over his shoulder when he was in Vienna
in Civil War then t'challa in a suit with his
mask off then the script quote t'chella asked his
father in The ancestral plane tell me how to best
protect wakanda I want to be a great king then the
script quote t'challa said before the U.N in times
of Crisis the wise build Bridges while the foolish
build barriers then an image of black panther with
a mask on then the script quote what happens
now determines what happens to the rest of the
world which I think was just a line for the Black
Panther trailer marketing throughout 2017 and 2018
then the script quote if anyone found out what we
truly are and what we possess they could destroy
the world it's my duty to protect it which is an
alternate line for the movie that t'challa said
to Nakia when they walk through the streets
in Black Panther and then t'challa Crossing
his arms in salute then we see the letters of
Marvel Studios where the flickering images are
more famous moments of t'challa yeah I'm gonna be
honest I did not notice did you notice The Script
quotes at all I didn't process them it's like yeah
I saw the words and I think in the back of my mind
I was just like oh they're always there but yeah
and especially it's fascinating that they would
pull alternate quotes or or moments that didn't
actually like appear in the movie like I feel like
there has to be some level of intent there but
yeah I didn't process that they were his lines
certainly well I mean a big part of actors is
they make lines their own so if there's like an
alternate take I could imagine that it was just
the way he decided to deliver that line or choose
some of his own grammar in the moment because
sometimes you might change it just a tiny bit
in this verb being in the moment I think it was
kind of cool that they chose the original lines
that he would have to work off of to birth his
character highlights yeah his interaction with the
process too yeah t'challa walking Industries lab
in the 2018 film t'challa celebrating at Warrior
Falls after he defeated mbaku t'challa hugging his
father to Chaka in the ancestral plane in the 2018
film The Moment t'challa drops out of the royal
Talon fighter to help Nakia in the 2018 film then
on the inside of the V to Chala swinging from
the Rhino horn in the battle of the 2018 film
then on the r to challenge shuri stepping out of
the portal in endgame to give cap some backup and
then on the M t'challa shouting the words wakanda
forever an Infinity War right before the charge
and it ends as it has throughout many phase four
titles clearing all of these images with t'challa
punching the ground to release the shock wave and
behind all this is a purple Hue the color of the
heart-shaped herb fitting beautiful and poignant
tribute we transitioned one year later Queen
Ramona played by Angela Bassett in a powerful
truly osworthy performance addresses the U.S who
tries to shame her for not sharing what kind of
vibranium with the outside world Richard Schiff
Toby Ziegler from The West Wing is credited as the
U.S Secretary of State an office switched during
the Civil War era was held by Thaddeus Ross in
the MCU rip to Thunderbolt Ross William Hurt
as well as leader of the merchant tribe Dorothy
Steele who plays a small role in this movie but
also died during production the French secretary
States right the vibranium cannot be detected by
known metal detectors as we saw in the 2018 film
when t'challa Nakia and nokoye entered that Korean
nightclub Ramona defends the wakandan's actions
as safeguards against the hostility of other
nations saint she knows they whispered the king
is dead the Black Panther is gone and now is the
time to strike calling out there Trails of their
Goodwill the last time wakanda appeared before
the U.N and we actually see these actions at a
wakandan Outreach Center in onsongo Mali one of
the many Outreach centers to challengeuri opened
around the world including one in Oakland that we
saw at the end of the 2018 film oh yeah whatever
happens that Oakland Outreach Center I don't know
I mean I feel like they could use it down the
line and I feel like if Ryan coogler comes back
it would be interesting to see because Oakland is
you know he's I think he grew up there and is a
big part of his you know stories so I feel like
it was very intentional to place one there so I
mean there's stuff you could do with that in the
future it still carries on with Nokia helping out
people in Haiti they did end the movie with the
for the last one with that yeah so I thought they
would carry through with that in some way here
maybe the shuri will go and protect Oakland while
umbaku watches uh wakanda French Commandos attack
these scientists but a koi leads dorm Elijah to
the rescue and we find out that one of these signs
is actually one of the dormologically undercover
Anika played by Michaela Cole she uses vibranium
daggers against okoya's insistence I want to see
more of her I may destroy you have someone here
suggested they must have anticipated this attack
and or other Outreach centers have already been
raided and we learn in a Twist this attack had
already happened hours before the U.N speech
so the dorm Elijah escort these Commandos to
the U.N to shame the French shame the French to
this incursion be an olive branch yeah okoya is
French and other non-english languages in this
movie it's translated into subtitles the color
white wakandan is always translated into yellow
and the language italocon is translated into
blue and of course it's hard to hear the word
incursion in the MCU not think of Reed Richards
warning us about incursions heading to Secret Wars
and multicrous Madness we should note that in the
2015 John Hickman New Avengers run that kicks
off that Illuminati freakout over incursions
that seems to be Marvel Studios road map for how
we're leading to that the initial incursion Point
appears where over the Skies over wakanda then on
to an ocean Expedition that's what Angela Bassett
was talking about the kind vibranium detector to
investigate an underwater drill that got busted on
a deposit of vibranium they're led by Dr Graham
actress Lake Bell who voices Natasha Romanov on
what if the telecon Warriors Dart passed them in
the shadows and we hear louder and louder their
siren song the diver Salazar and Jackson get
transfixed by a phantom jellyfish before the
teleconians kill them I gotta imagine this was
at least a nod from Kugler to Jordan peel for
the jellyfish inspired UFO jeans jacket and nope
which hypnotically led people but we got a note
in this movie not that kind of Doom I mean and
it's hard for me to imagine that considering they
both came out this year yeah and I mean yeah the
jellyfish makes a lot of sense to be down there
and they do make other allusions to jellyfish in
this movie specifically so it felt more motivated
internally than if it's that's the Jordan Peele
tribute I would have never spotted it and I would
absolutely have needed someone to suggest that
the teleconians break the surface of the water
and sing hypnotizing crew members to walk off
the deck into the water this is based on Sirens
of Greek mythology humanoid creatures who would
lure Sailors to their Shores with their songs
but then cause those Sailors to crash on the rocks
of the islands a Tuma nomura and other telekines
bore the ship in attack in the comics atuma is a
rival to Namor but here he's kind of a second in
command wow that sounds like a massive change yep
learning a lot today about how much neymore and
Company have changed and especially I mean like
it makes it's really cool the way they orchestrate
his beef with akoye but at the same time I'm like
we did get that name we're moving maybe that'll be
the conflict be a little bit like what happened
internally moving going wrong in Black Panther
the first one you know when there were alliances
forming against within the kingdom itself yeah
exactly and then you know like he has to convince
namura at the end so maybe a Tuma comes in he's
like I don't buy that yeah he's weak yeah I'm
gonna take over now lead with strength they all
wear breathing masks filled with water so that
they can move on land similar to the moisture
masks of the still suits in Doom Dr Graham departs
in a helicopter but it crashes revealed to have
been thrown by its tail by Namor flying with his
ankle wings and we cross dissolve from this into
the border of wakanda making it look like no more
is flying into that Kingdom as this will be the
next place he visits going to wakanda right now
Cooper cameos reported on the U.N speech you look
closely at the ticker along the bottom of the
screen it reads Scott Lane continues to promote
his book look out for the little I don't think
that's it at all which of course is the next
film on Marvel studioslate Ramona finds that's
an Easter egg we're sure he's designing the EXO
suits that will eventually become okoye's Midnight
Angel suits the wakanda letters on shuri's screen
translate to Flat Line which might just be
one of her design template tool option but
also might just be an unfortunate word combination
reminding her of how a year earlier she found out
her brother flatlined in the same spot yeah the
Ramona says that the AI agree out a nerves her
saying one day artificial intelligence is going
to kill us all and sure he says AI isn't like
the movie's mother it does exactly what I tell
it Age of Ultron pretty unexchange for a world
that has definitely had to deal with ultra yeah
she wants to take her on a trip telling her to
leave behind her because bracelet and her kaboyo
earrings setting up Sherry to have two separate
ways of tracking her after she leaves behind her
bracelet on the bridge Ramona takes shuri to a
Riverside campfire to partake in a morning ritual
of Bernie in the funeral garments I think that's
really smart to do that too because there's like
no form of real protection they have other than
the Spears and Neymar shows up yeah it's very
Elemental that way it's very vulnerable for
them in that situation nearby elephants bathed
in the river elephants are known to have complex
grieving rituals as well traveling long distances
to the sites on the anniversaries of the deaths of
family members Guided by an instinct similar
to the hand of t'challa's spirit that Ramona
mentions here but sure he always a scientist is
a skeptic I gotta point this out did you hear
that story a couple months ago where I think it
was an elephant's parent or elephant's child was
um you know uh murdered and then uh
the elephant found the one who did it
killed him and then when the funeral took place
later the at the same elephant came back and
stamped through that funeral what yeah that's ins
elephants are known to have us they're in a strong
memory and yes they are extremely extremely
emotional the John Wick of elephants I want
that Revenge movie elephant is not messing around
man she says the hand was a construct of Ramona's
mind shuri says if I sit here and think about my
brother for too long it won't be these clothes I
burn it will be the world and everyone in it now
later when shuri enters the ancestral plane she
wears these funeral garments as the room around
her catches fire so in this moment she talks
about birding the world she is invoking killmonger
and his rage Ramona nearly tells sharia's secret
about t'challa they are interrupted by Namor
now the comics Namor was the Submariner ruler
of Atlantis Marvel's first mutant when he was
introduced in timely Comics 1939 but here the
character's been reconceled by Ryan coogler to be
played by tenochuerta from the realm of telecon
but still having the pointy ears and the ankle
Wings Nemours says yeah this place is amazing
the air is pristine damn is this scene online
my mother told stories about a place like this a
protected land with people that never had to leave
never have to change who they were what reason
do you have to rebuild your secret to the world
I am not a woman who enjoys repeating herself who
are you I have many names my people oh Google God
well my enemies call me no more is The Feathered
Serpent deity worshiped by the ancient Mayans
an Aztec afterlife that takes in those who die
from drowning or anything associated with rain
or water the native language is based on ancient
Mayan languages sure he observes that horizontal
vibranium meaning that she could just kind of
eyeball his metallic chess pieces and pearls
and tell that they are all vibranium despite their
different color and texture from the vibranium she
works with she's such an expert she just knows
vibranium when she sees it and the more leaves
ramonda with the American vibranium detector and a
vibranium conch shell to call him and I just love
this oh it's vibranium this is what I was told
as a Florida kid that when you put a shell up to
your ear you can hear the ocean nope you're really
hearing them all the Council of Elders gatherers
tribe the Elders of the River tribe carrot and
baku's carrots Baku enters this room he eats him
a call back to his line in the 2018 film one
more word and I will feed you to my children
I'm kidding we have vegetarians the door
milage stand on columns for the different
parts of the Kingdom on the columns are written
Golden City kingsguard River tribe mining tribe
behind each guard are the Tableau symbols in
red clay just like the floor of this throne
room they originally designed this throne
room so we made it the same clay so that
all the different rulers of the different
tribes would all stand on the same terrain
one of these symbols is a large tree with
expansive branches and equally expansive
roots in the past I've gone through this to the
each or so worlds tree of Asgardian mythology
but in this case I like the symbolism of As
Above So Below as above we have the kingdom
of wakanda as below we have the kingdom of
talukan now behind each door milage Garden
rest in Power King t'challa our hero twas an honor
wakanda forever wow wow really oh that's beautiful
people gonna get that tattooed loyalty actor Isaac
debeccalay plays the River tribe Elder as he did
in the 2018 film and surmises that no more must
have swum he says 100 kilometers to bypass the
River border makes us Wonder a bit about the
wakanda feed because it is certainly more than
100 kilometers to the nearest ocean or sea based
on the map of wakanda from Civil War but it would
be within 100 kilometers of Lake Victoria which
would be a nearby lake that no more could swim to
up the Nile for the Mediterranean Sea working
on this geography in other videos but I think
the math does check out there I don't even think
Kevin feige knows where exactly where it's located
I think the Vegas like Springfield the vagueness
is your is your asset somewhere somewhere in
Africa yeah yeah you know where where's is it
connectable by a river or another body of water
you know that's fine then yeah I don't think we're
ever gonna know exactly where it's located yeah
it's not a real place people [Laughter]
technically only one and nowhere else
Ramona Sherry nikoye deduce that there must have
been a second vibranian meteorite that landed in
the ocean which means for them the one gift from
the heavens that made wakanda unique a vibranium
meteorite was also a gift that the cosmos gave to
the ocean of Earth but it also poses a question
where in the cosmos did all these cheating I
look forward to exploring that many of the other
questions from this movie in future videos but
ever at Ross which is the 2018 film and tells sure
we head to MIT remember this is Tony Stark's
alma mater and currently the college attended
by MJ Ned and Flash sure that's right
Dominique Thorne future ironheart Thor
actually initially auditioned for the role
of shuri for the 2018 film and you can tell
there's an inherent Sisterhood between the
two women as intellectual equals kind of like
what we initially saw between Tony Stark and
Peter Parker Tom Holland origination for Army
conjecture three three plus one this refers
to the 3x plus one problem of the Colette's
conjecture that's the most famous unsolved
problem in mathematics presumably this is
what Riri is actively working on in her Spare
Time inside bravery's room is the flag of the
city of Chicago that is her hometown and akoye
gets impatient get out of my dorm get out hey I'm
warning you do not take another step toward me see
how they teach the children to treat their guests
I like it hey hey hey hey put him down put
it you hurt yourself come on it's all right
princess small small girl I am going to give you
two options you can come to wakanda conscious or
unconscious yeah remember in the 2018 film makoya
used an itchy wig to go undercover in the outside
world in Korea now she just covers her head
tattoos with makeup but it presents its own
complication they go to riri's Warehouse where
she said she had to build a quantum computer to
crack her own encryption Quantum you say I mean
the future technology in the MCU is certainly
Quantum Riri actually could have been the friend
who helped Cassie Lang build that Quantum Tech
that leads your Avengers yes not just an
ironhearted asking if it's quote Stark Tech
so it's not just that shuri is building her own
exosuit inspired by Iron Man she is actually using
start text schematics means she might be building
this with Tony's blessing through one of those MIT
grants like the one that he announced in Civil War
since he would have been like eight years before
this but I assume the grant program is still
functioning I think it's smart to lean into that
instead of trying to ignore the fact of how Iron
Man it is yeah and they do in the movie there's so
many things that are like so reminiscent of Iron
Man yeah for sure and I think it brings it it down
to earth it's like okay yeah there's something
I can refer to from Tony Stark's work and I feel
like that is a way to have Tony still touch and be
able to tech people up but in a way that doesn't
feel as much like you're skipping past something
like it can with Spider-Man Riri says there's an
entire YouTube channel dedicated to sightings of
me like there's another Peter Parker parallel with
Civil War and homecoming showing YouTube videos of
Peter's heroics throughout Queens this might also
be an account you can imagine Paula Khan having
something to do with either posting content there
or definitely replying to it Okoye takes off in a
muscle car short on a motorcycle and re-ray Suits
up in her Mark 1 armor when it Powers up notice
it makes the same sound effect as Tony starts for
pulsers oh cool use that Marvel sounds like that's
like my favorite suit of all the suits that Riri
wears in this yes yes a thousand percent but here
there's no full coverage of the body it's really
just like bars and straps and rigging and zip
ties and she has this chest reactor in the shape
of art the whole Escape is just very reminiscent
of Tony Stark's initial escape from the cave and
his unfinished Mark 1 suit in the first Iron Man
film Riri makes its rapid climb into the night sky
but she runs out of oxygen and Falls reminding us
a lot of Tony's first real flight over Los Angeles
when he froze over and fell and just caught
himself at the last second rigor catches herself
here and Glides along the river Sharia nicoye flee
the FBI sure he uses her spear to Anchor her turn
a government drone closes in on them Hariri shoots
it down and joins the other two in a victory slide
over the wreckage until don't think she killed
any of those cops though I feel like that's so bad
when she did though it's debatable for certain and
I mean that drone collateral damage just blew up
three cruisers at least so I mean yeah I feel like
it's not so egregious that you can't chalk it up
to like yeah there's always collateral damage but
also I mean yeah she did murder a few people or
manslaughter like literally myself like damn you
might just kill those cops right there it's bold
and whale the actors actually said this duel
between Okoye and natuma took the longest of
any fight sequence in the film to shoot as they
kept having to go back and read parts of it I love
how a tomb of strike back on her feet she has a
vibranium Spear and she is not used to ever having
to repel other vibranium with it so defeated
shuri requests that Tyler canal take her and
Riri to meet nemour directly I can imagine it's
like for me yeah imagine like also the time it
you got a specific time of day you have to shoot
it has to be in when this guy is not freaking
bright a prominent bridge and then you also have
to get everyone in the makeup yeah for hours and
then just the reshooting of upon reshooting it's
just crazy to know like it's less than 10 minute
sequence and then people just walk moose fun but
it is heartening I do appreciate that since the
discourse has begun a lot of at least several
people we've heard from have pointed to that as
being their favorite actions I'm glad that that
worked paid off yeah they'll fall those four
months the next morning Everett Ross arrives
at this crime scene where he meets Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine Julie Louis Dreyfus the
shadowy government figure from the Falcon Winter
Soldier and black widow who is now established
as of this film as the current CIA director in
the MCU and Ross's ex-wife this is a huge deal for
the political hierarchy of the MCU this is what I
was referring to in my tweet when I said that the
hierarchy power of the EMC was changing and I said
I'll leave gonna get mad at me when you find out
what it was but yeah I think it's extremely small
I was wondering Val has been the CIA director
because John Walker didn't really seem to know she
was and the CIA director is a president-nominated
and Senate approved very public figure well the
average person might not know the CIA director is
it's not like John Walker would know but either
way this means that Val's recruitment of Walker
and recruitment of Elena belova to kill Hawkeye
all of these things said the full weight of the US
government behind it and now since Val is going to
be leading the Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts is
going to be a much more public Squad of killers
I think this is definitely going to tie into
secret Invasion and Captain America New World
Order and yeah Thunderbolts and Val just shot
at the top of my list as scroll suspicious
and ever at Ross right behind her however
Ross is a scroll scroll Ross no I would be
bummed I mean you know I'll happily Embrace
that scroll but he's got such a personality
I think that would undercut so much of it and I
like the idea too of Val being a scroll and then
whatever rostv keep thinking about their marriage
yes the fact that they were married I'm like what
Drew these two people together because one guy
seems so nice like he comes across like a little
bit tough especially in Civil War yeah but he's
such a nice guy you know yeah absolutely and
Val's like such a [__] maybe maybe the real vow
when they were married was nicer and more fun our
MCU CIA director is way hotter than the real RCA
director oh my God yeah the the public the America
the real the government should take notes reports
losing shuri and Riri the doorways behind her are
now flanked with text on sacred ground may we find
and on the other side the wisdom of the ancestors
now it actually seems to be a misprint in the
shot of a koye but it is what it reads later
when sure he enters the ancestral plane version
of this room when it transforms into literal
sacred ground where shuri finds the wisdom I'll
be a complex wisdom of her ancestors raimonda is
reminded that akoye raised her spear against her
own husband referring to wakati Daniel kaluya's
character from the 2018 film who does not appear
in this movie but Ramona says that will copy is
somewhere that Okoye can visit him anytime she
wishes so this is that wakabi is alive and well
somewhere Ramona shouts are you Queen of the most
powerful nation in the world and my entire family
everything God damn it either with great power
comes great loss Ramona also snaps yes standing
at killmonger's side when she and sure he had to
flee to the mountains something I was surprised
to hear she still have a grudge over but it's
all coming out and it hurts Okoye resigns for
spear say I get why Ramona would be upset by
by all this I feel like she she reached like
breaking point because she's had to display
such strength of leadership and I think that
scene is so powerful because that was her boiling
point I can't lose my daughter now I told you you
shouldn't bring her you insisted now she's gone
use your job after all the [__] you've been
through I didn't even give you crap about what
happened with you I've already cut you the slack
you're asking for killmongeria yeah totally she
doesn't have time to be emotional it all came out
there that was this is gut wrenching it's kind
of crazy to see that scene because it's it's
gut-wrenching for a koye and it's gut wrenching
for Ramona and they have two very different sides
here and you just feel so much pain for both of
them because when nikoya is fired you're like no
Ramona finds Nakia in an orphanage in Haiti and
we catch a quick glimpse of a boy who later gets
revealed in the post-credit scene to Saint
played by young actor Divine love konadu's
son and the post credit scene is revealed as
t'challa inakiyah Sun t'challa son of t'challa
that's a familiar greeting between the boy
and his grandmother he was at the premiere
there's 140 meters below kind of a
middle ground man cave for no more
to be alone and to paint because yeah you
can't paint underwater but I also love that
Nemours keeps painting because that's such
a traditional way of keeping the stories
documenting it through history as opposed to
any of the many modern day technological events
he's like no I'm gonna keep this tradition going
with paintings on the wall to tell the story yeah
it's beautiful sure he has told to put on a
traditional telecon dress rear says it's some
super villain [__] like Princess Leia referring
to the slave Leia bikini and Return of the Jedi
Belle from Beauty and the Beast and she says that
white chick from Indiana Jones referring to when
Marion had to put on the white dress and Raiders
of Lost Ark but Bell from Beauty and the Beast
there wasn't anything that messed up about that
I mean I guess it's kind of weird that a bunch of
like clocks and candles and dishware is like yeah
put on that sexy dress for that Beast this whole
movie's kind of Stockholm syndrome that's great
she's in the Yucatan in Mexico never watched that
movie it's the same again there's quite subtitles
but the moment she switches to ancient Mayan the
language of talocon the subtitle switched the
color blue now more brings shuri into his painting
room re-explains his backstory with his mother in
1571 in Zama which was the original name of Tulum
which is one of the best preserved Mayan cities
on the coastal Yucatan Spanish conquistadores
gave them small box now 1571 this would be about
50 years after the eternals witnessed the Spanish
conquering of the Aztec capital and then parted
ways you could argue had they finished the job we
might not have gotten no more namora says they
pray ah fascinating my eternals are relevant
Jack is the Mayan Reign deity but NASDAQ mythology
that God is named slalok who rules over slalo Khan
namora says shock LED them to a plant underwater
sprouting from a vibranium Rock their heart-shaped
herb but an herb that grows underwater namora's
mother ingests his plant along with the rest of
the tribe and they wake up with blue skin
gas paper air having to dive into the water
so they can breathe where their skin turns
back a normal color so other than fascinated
by this detail it'll turn blue only when they
are out of water we see the birth of nemour as
her son of Holocaust the wings on his feet and
ears that he says were pointed to the sky and
he calls himself a mutant he says that he
has the ability to age slowly and breathe
both through air and through water in the MCU
we're still Gathering what the rules of mutant
kind are but it seems like every mute must have
some kind of genetic precondition that leads to
their physical States turning out different from
everyone else but it also presents the question
do all mutants age slowly because according to
the latter Fox X-Men films that definitely seem
to be the case well what does the word mutant
mean let's scales get the actual definition
yes it could be like a double meaning here
resulting from showing the effect of mutation
fascinating an organism that is different from
others of its type because of permanent changes
in its genes yeah see he could have just been
saying that on a very literal level sure as
opposed to I was a mutant you know what mutants
are you know mutants are this you're going to
be seeing a lot more of these moving forward
I think you just got one recently it could
have been uh just the right choice of words
to establish him as yes he is a mutant but
maybe in that sentence he was just referring to
himself as this the literal definition of what
a mutant is of our genes were mutated by this
herb and then I was born with these mutations
passed on genetically without having to take the
herbs so thus I am a mutant yeah yeah yeah but
it's also simultaneously saying he's a mutant
the X-Men you know well this mother's dying
wish young the more returns to the land where
he finds a slave plantation and a priest says
Thou Art a demon Son Of Satan not yet Padre but
Mephisto is coming soon the teleconneal burned
the plantation and the more reveals the origin
of his given name that they called him El Nino
SI nemour the boy without love I love the little
little baby it looks like a Party City costume
a little short little belt one of our kids
are going to be going his name more in the
every pool party not summer these are really
revealing never for a little boy cover up son
the boy without love which she embraced as he
has no love for the service world so Namor it
wasn't just to know chuerta pronouncing it
differently they actually worked in a bit
of Spanish wordplay to cast no more as proudly
without love for humans no more gives Shari a
deep snowboard to show her talocon and at first
I wondered wait where did the teleconil get
these until he raised oh right yes Salazar and
Jackson second time it hit me was just murdered
in nice have fun nope it doesn't smell bad so
namora takes jury down through this tunnel in
the water which seems to be a kind of current
but I don't know maybe it's a type of Waypoint
to a hidden Earthly realm kind of like that
watery portal that leads to talo and shung
Chi now I know China and Mexico are different
countries with completely different cultures
and histories I'm just saying get out of
here racist hidden mythological comes on
Earth there might be a connection there the
amazing and the baltalo yeah for instance
which is revealed from Mayan script
translating to English the way other
location titles translate from wakan into English
the Tamil played the Mesoamerican ball game Pete's
modern version known as ulama this
was played by Mayan peoples where a
rubber ball is bounced from your hip through
a hoop on the wall you might know it as I did
salute forming their hands kind of in the shape
of a throne but also an open shark mouth as the
telecon throne is a giant shark Jabba also kind
of looks like hadouken or like I regret that joke
immediately now more show his Central Palace
that is made fully a vibranium and is lit by
a powerful light his own Golden City that he must
protect Nakia Waits on a line about the sun track
shury's earrings and then dives into a water hole
in the jungle a land-based waypoint to talocon
now notice how nakia's suit is green the color of
her River tribe but costume designer Ruth e Carter
Incorporated blue to look like a river snaking
Through the Jungle effectively telling the story
of nakia's rescue plot in the second act the more
gives shuri a gracefully the French same bracelet
worn by his mother both an olive branch but we
later learned the plant DNA that shuri can use
to re-synthesize the heart-shaped herb so just to
track the jewelry swapping going on in this movie
sure he leaves her camoyo bead bracelet for Ross
to find technically Val bug that bracelet but she
keeps her earrings which is how they track her
down meanwhile no more notices that shuri's wrist
is bare as she surrenders himself to him which
she knows that he won't see is suspicious because
she was not wearing that bracelet earlier at the
Riverside fire ritual smart Quest so nomore gives
her a bracelet which becomes the Cure that she's
been seeking throughout this whole film I love it
when costumes symbolic function in the film shuri
tells no more yes yes yeah good catch we finally
asked for help she couldn't now this is a nod to
Chadwick Boseman in real life who was diagnosed
with colon cancer in 2016 and he told pretty much
no one he suffered in silence while shooting Black
Panther and infinity war and end game Ryan coogler
recently told Anna he see coats in a podcast that
he noticed Bozeman would struggle during the
warrior fall scenes in the 2018 film and at the
time coogler didn't really know why some days
when I would find him doing things that were
kind of inexplicable like we would do these these
things in the water you know the waterfall stuff
so it would take him like a long time to warm back
up like you have to be in like in a warm intake
like a long time and I'll be like I'll be like
man I'll be like that's odd you know you know
I'm saying things like that or you know some some
days I was Finding just like incredibly sad but
looking back I'm like oh man my man's was dying
it's a shocking thing to realize and it's also
a thing where it's like oh yeah I can't quit If
he if he did all that while he was going through
that you know this is just grief so it's like we
gotta push through that is so freaking powerful
like it's heartbreaking but also inspiring in
many ways it's such perseverance and discipline
mind over body yeah and and some of the wildest
ways you know like he didn't want to be looked at
it I don't know what it was specifically I don't
want anyone want to try to guess what it was that
Chadwick Boseman uh was probably going through you
know clearly he was incredibly private about it
to know that and like even the people around him
just weren't made aware of it and he didn't want
to put that out there it still fought through
it it's just that's just so insane to me it's
so insane yeah and the fact that you can't tell
by looking at it to like the amount of internal
like it makes you wonder on top of all the other
preparation physical and as an actor like what
mental wherewithal and spiritual wherewithal
had to have been drawn from to sell those scenes
and to commit to doing that instead of like you
know you you have a tremendous illness you have
every excuse in a lot of ways to you know not
necessarily go that far to committing to this
gift to everybody you know to me I'm like yeah
that's like a real life leader in a real life
Warrior and so that's another reason why I think
it was important to do a movie that really honors
Chadwick Postman no more tells shuri my ancestors
would often say only the most broken people can
be great leaders he's trying to appeal to her
grief as a kind of complement of wisdom but the
more reveals the whole point of all this that he
plans to attack the surface world preemptively and
he wants straight to get wakanda to join them
in that war and while he seems crazy they see
mikatsu converts that to be essentially the case
the Secretary of State tells Val and Ross that
the president plans to invade wakanda the more
meets Ramon on the beach and warns her that he
will kill her if any further intrusions happen
to telecon Meanwhile Nakia arrives in history
and riri's Telecom he'll guard with a fatal blast
sure he reunites with her mother no more returns
to find that dying guard and nomura goats him to
strike back so no more descends to his sharkbone
throne where it looks like the teeth are actually
made of vibranium he wears a feathered serpent
headpiece of cuckoo Khan I like the symbolic
contrast in the directional coronation of the
two King wakanda's ruler Rises up from the
ancestral plane to set the throne telecon's
ruler descends down from the Sun to sit that
Throne telecon angrily rallies his people to war
Nakia reunites with the koye in wakanda
okoya says that Nikia left right after
thanos's attack when you left without saying
a word you did how you regret not being there
with all of you it was not easy he was
King and black panther to everyone to me
this means that Nakia was pregnant with t'challa's
son at the time of thanos's snap in the Battle of
wakanda and notice how here Nakia catches
herself she almost says t'challa was also
the father to her son but she just says that he
was everything which she was behind Nakia water
just slowly starts to flood into the streets
I don't even notice it at first okoya just
begins to say we are under attack but then the
water bombs explode throughout the streets now
Namor flooding wakanda was a plot point in 2012
Avengers vs X-Men comic storyline that's when the
Phoenix Force possesses Neymar and uses him to
flood wakanda when the nation Harbors Avengers
Neymar and t'challa have a bitter hatred for
each other ever since that in the comics okay
grabs a kid as the water gushes and hands
him off Ayo and the other door milage save
some rescue workers who get enchanted by the
teleconneal siren songs shuri and Anika pilot
an aircraft to save a trolley we actually saw
one of these on the streets in the 2018 film
it's just pretty satisfying to see all levels of
wakandans immediately spring in to help each other
namora joins atuma and nomura on the shoreline
and it's like an actual civilians being held
tap on his arm and the more punches him right
in the chest breaking his chest armor right now
I know if he's rounding up water is the
strongest Hulk I actually recently broke
the Avatar of a God that kind of checks out with
the mcu's internal Logic the more zigzags through
the air defenses he does his mid-air turn with
his foot passing the camera showing his ankle
Wings flapping over time no more flies up to
the throne room to face off with ramonda and
Riri inside he stabs his spear into the glass
and cracks it then throws water grenades and
floods the room Ramon is able to save Riri
but she drowns and sure he is inconsolable
so shuri has to go through another Royal burial
this time for her mother now ironically my damn
bold move funeral garments before she left him to
be used again just imagine how horrible it is you
just were closer to your brother's funeral and
before they even have a chance to gather Dusty
gotta put them back on for your mother I do want
to put this I put this on the live stream but I
do think that I wish we had a scene of Riri
afterwards that dealt with her feeling like
guilty I've heard the criticisms of Riri
Williams in this film she's feeling like an
iron heart setup I was saying in the live stream
I think what would have really helped Focus up her
narrative in the film and the integral part of
her being here would have been if after Ramona
dies you know because in the whole movie she's
kind of like I didn't even do anything why is
he coming after me and I didn't I didn't intend
for any of this but then after Ramona dies being
like it's feeling like it's her fault Ramona died
because Ramona tried saving her went to save her
and then none of this maybe would have happened
if Riri didn't do any of this and then sure he
could have like motivated her to be like well
then you just gotta put the everything you do
to do something good and help me fight back yeah
I mean think of how I must be feeling if I'm in a
fight you can join me yeah and together we can
at least make something better it would have
made Earhart's appearance too in the finale feel
even cooler and more powerful and like yeah make
her part of the Journey of grief and guilt and all
that too and then she has a line about her dad in
the end yeah it could resonate over that together
yeah the answer woes is literally tattooed on her
hand a double helix configuration with orbs her
attempt at the recipe for the heart-shaped herb
and now on the same wrist is the final ingredient
she needs nemour's mother's bracelet that is made
from that plant meanwhile Val confronts her
ex-husband Ross on his contact with wakanda
Anderson Cooper cameos again but this time the
new sticker reads Ritson signed trade pact with
new Asgard to create something but this is not
to the new U.S president who's gonna be played
by Dermot Mulroney in secret invasions oh no way
U.S president secretary of state Toby Ziegler ncia
director Val it's still great they're really
setting up secret information in this movie
is
it bring him against the United States and asked
Valance she's ever thought what the U.S would be
doing if we were the only country in the world to
add vibranium and Val's response is interesting
she says oh I actually dream about that I think
it's a little ahead that one of Val's objectives
is to amass all the vibranium and weaponry under
government control or at least under her control
and maybe the mission she's going to deploy
the Thunderbolts on is an invasion of or a
heist from wakanda or since Bucky's lead in that
team may be a collaboration with the door milage
to steal back vibranium from some other third
party who steals it like the real intelligencia
I don't feel like Bucky would ever no matter if
he's part of the Thunderball he is not going to
invade he will be inciting Institute of film
they try to test him with task him with this
Mission and he just quits yeah there's no way he's
attacking wakanda so the Golden City evacuates to
the Jabari Outpost shury and reread deduce that
nemour absorbs oxygen through his skin and thus
will be weakened by dehydration Rivier gets to
work on new Iron Art harmer made from vibranium
she hammers out a piece in the shape of a heart
sharing gives Okoye her completed Midnight Angel
suit in the comics sure he is able to synthesize
the heart-shaped her of DNA from the bracelet
and when it prints it successfully glows so sure
he sips the liquid and falls into the ancestral
plane as not pray for her now structurally this
mirrors the leap of faith at the end of Act 2 in
the 2018 film when the women resurrected t'challa
to restore wakanda's protector shuri immediately
finds herself in an ancestral plane mirror of the
real world underwater in the flooded throne room
in the exact same spot where her mother Ramona's
life left her body just like how when killmonger
went to the ancestral plane he visited the exact
spot of his parents tragic death sure he swims
up to the surface and she's again wearing her
White Funeral garments but as she Rises out of
the water her clothes are dry I must have shot
that backwards Leticia Wright and Ryan coogler
might have shot this in Reverse yeah yeah you see
there is someone sitting on the throne behind her
suddenly we all feel a mix of dread because none
of us want to see a CGI Recreation of Chadwick
Boseman it can't be him it can't be so instead the
ghost who greets us is killmonger Michael B Jordan
making a surprise Cameo which comes that's both
the relief but also an intriguing Haunting of its
own the scene that follows is my favorite scene
in the film cutting deep to the core conflict of
this film while also recontextualizing everything
we saw in the 2018 film remember the answer extra
plane is not an objective afterlife it's really
a personalized Vision where the visitor is able
to confront their ancestors there's some Cosmic
forces at play that decide who you actually need
to talk to one could say this is a request coming
from one's own soul but for t'challa it was to
rage against his father for killing and jobu and
abandoning for killmonger it was his chance to
revisit the Oakland apartment where his father
died but who does Sherry see she sees her cousin
killmonger who taunts her saying you chose me
and he challenges her for not even believing the
ancestral plane was real but just took the
Earth for the same reason he did to avenge
Fallen ancestors now remember as much as this is
killmonger talking to her we could totally look at
this as shuri having a conversation with herself
and all of a sudden I'm guessing she's been doing
about killmonger over the past several years so
why did Sherry seek killmonger she already chose
him earlier in the film when she said at that
Riverside campfire that she wanted to burn the
world down that was killmonger's goal and notice
how in this scene the throne room ignites the same
way killmonger set the heart-shaped herb garden
Ablaze and left Sherry with that medical crisis
here killmonger defends himself he says I had the
courage do what was necessary to change wakanda
how many people like your scientists to wakanda
protect before I took the throne cowards those
are the Panthers who came before me and before
t'challa sure he tells killmonger that he was
coward we're taking a last Urban burning the rest
out of fear of being replaced that he left wakanda
with no protector and that's a challenge Ramona's
blood is on his hands the killmonger responds
don't you dare take that away from your mother
she sacrificed her life to protect a girl from
The Lost tribe your father he was a hypocrite
he would have killed that girl [__] he killed
his own brother t'challa he was too Noble he led a
man who killed your father live and here you stand
are you gonna be Noble like your brother or take
care of business like me killmonger calls Riri a
member of this tribe which is how he saw himself
and all other black people outside of wakanda the
lives that he fought for killmonger also invokes
Zemo who killed tachaka and t'challa for gave Zemo
at the end of Civil War I like to think that Zemo
at this moment stiffened in his cell on the Wrath
feeling to shiver down his spine so then just
resume dancing to see killmonger eternally sitting
on the throne now again shuri has subconsciously
summoned him here but this visual presents a
hypothetical that killmonger could be in a kind of
Hell of his own making where he's sitting on the
the throne that he always wanted but ruling
over a vacant dead kingdom while all other
Panther ancestors joined together in a communion
as Panthers in a tree killmonger tragically will
always be part of a lost tribe of one oh [__]
yeah that's a great Point that's a really great
deep point that even in the ancestral plane just
a visual I'm sure like especially if he's still
is behaving that way man after death it thinks
that way I could see him being like oh [__]
we're dead there's plenty of ancestral
plane for you to take up don't just come
over here with your bad energy all
right you're trying to be wise in a
turn over here there's no more grudges
it's always gonna be a load out there
no I mean that's the powerful part of this shury's
whole dilemma is she could either go the path of
her brother or go the path to killmonger you know
obviously we know which passion ends up taking I
think that's one of the beautiful conflicts and a
way of honoring what's come before again so yeah
that was that was funny though yeah man it'll be
a what if episode that just all takes place in the
ancestral plane and the workplace comedy so that
I thought he might have softened up a little bit
nope this scene ends before Sherry can even answer
killmonger's question framing it as a haunting
nightmare that she's still trying to figure out
for the rest of the film she's afraid to tell
others who she saw in that Vision out of shame
because killmonger was a symptom of her own moral
illness that this physician still needs to heal
but sure he still has super strength and she suits
up in a new suit she places her helmet beside the
helmet of her brother the helmet that she carried
in the opening funeral scenes now she has a helmet
of her own and sure he joins everyone else at the
Jabari Outpost fully suited up interesting how
she joins by descending from above the way no
more set his throne sure he does not rise up
she drops down she's still being driven by the
misguided Vengeance that guides into more and
guided killmonger when she lands I like how the
impact spreads via purple kinetic energy as her
suit absorbs the shock of it I mean the Black
Panther Falls and lands yeah a lot several times
I mean it's a it's nice for her first appearance
that way but also I mean you know there's a lot of
jumping off and Landing a lot of other characters
do that too I'm sure it was really did it feel
everyone with you on the everything in talocon
when Neymar was doing it but at this moment if she
had landed on a throne then then maybe she's just
coming to talk with everybody you know you know
remember she's gonna rise up first to the ground
here to hold on the ground and fly up and through
it can we carve out a castle in a trap door so I
can get to this her helmet has a DOT pattern that
matches the war paint that she's worn from past
battles also on her gauntlets are open Panther
moths sure he leads wakandas out to the ocean
and lures the teleconil in battle she chants Evon
Bay that was t'challa's war Cripe in the Battle
of wakanda infinity War since the Moore's
punch broke his old chest plate mbaku suits
up with new armor burying the face of Hanuman
that's the APD the Jabari worship the telekinil
attacked for the backs of blue whales and orcas
their Shields I'm pretty sure the shells of sea
turtles awesome pulsing devices the wakandans
use to try to subdue them actually Jessica
Clemens interviewed Alex lubinali and Mabel Cadena
asking about their underwater work for this film
and Alex confirmed that Mabel holds the record
she's the champ are you holding the breath how
long no yeah no no wow you're gonna say that loud
six minutes you can hold your breath underwater
[Music] surrounded by glowing indicators much
like Iron Man's heads up display whatever controls
reads Max per I like how she also installed some
foot thrusters similar to Tony's Mark 50 armor in
Infinity War Riri shoots it into more from behind
but he's able to dodge the blast without looking
crazy good reflexes they're able to snare no more
on the Royal Talent fighter sure he uses hand
mounted Sonic cannons to repel the telekineal
like the ones that's used on killmonger in the
2018 film she claws down the side of the boat
kicking one telekineal throwing another Barrel
rolling and then sliding down since both her claws
and the whole of this boat are made a vibranium
they released blue Sparks from the friction and
from here she leaps into the Royal Talon fighter
where she tries to fly no more to a nearby desert
to finish him off but before they get there he's
able to use his spear to stab through the fighter
and wreck the engine causing it to crash leading
to this brutal Showdown the claws come out sure
and the more Slug It Out She Dodges this hook
and goes low slicing off some of his ankle Wings
he impales you on his spear so since it's pure
vibranium it goes through her suit's vibranium
weed I don't know why when they when it pulls off
that feathered wing it just you can feel it right
like oh yeah like I don't know what it's like to
have one of those but for some reason you're just
like oh that seems really I feel I feel like it's
painful I think it's the placement because the
ankle the ankle like anytime you watch a horror
movie and someone gets like I think that it was
there the Evil Dead pencil gag or something like
ankle I think is already an icky place for uh any
kind of you know painful gag and also too you know
it's a wing so it's like a smaller appendage so
I think you can relate it to like a finger or a
toe or a part of a foot you know like you can
feel the smaller more intimate pains than if
it had just been like I'm gonna cut you in half
it seems like it's all over as her life Fades
she's transported back to the ancestral plane the
burning Throne Room briefly her greatest fear that
being consumed with killmonger's ventral rage has
led her to death but instead she now rejects that
path she claws off the spear she pulls herself
off a bit somehow leaving no blood on the shaft of
that spear okay and leaps over to more and lands
before it and she uses the exploding jet engine
most effective just by drying him out even
further and as she holds the blade to his
throat both Fighters are close to death and they
sink in this fascinating interlocking visions of
their ancestors for sure the conflicts of the
past rewind we see the flooding in the battles
before reversing symbolizing her wounds beginning
to heal both the physical wounds in her suit and
her psychological illness her mind is retracing
its steps back to the mutually peaceful kingdoms
of wakanda and finally shuri sees the ancestor she
wanted to see in the ancestral plane a vision of
her mother Ramona who says show him who you
are and sure he tells them more to yield so
that Their Kingdoms can protect each other no
more looks at but sure he what does he see he
sees the vision of his mother reaching down
to him on the sacred ground every man there's
a mother of their ancestors a closing montages
shuri replanting the heart-shaped herb garden in
t'challa's Grain site she greets Riri in the
lab and makes a return didn't point out how
the mirrors on the bridge earlier not having this
super vibrating it's probably a good idea because
this way where he was going to be set up to build
a new DIY armor set in Iron Heart on Disney Plus
in 2023 we return to Warrior balls but instead of
shuri coming out of the royal Talent fighter it's
mbaku he says the Black Panther shuri sends her
regards but in Baku wishes to challenge for the
throne this sets up embaku to be the new ruler
of wakanda while sure he continues to be black
panther at least an intermediary one we catch
it back with him fights with a giant carrot cave
seems as though things are still a bit unresolved
and we realize no more has been painting all this
time a depiction of himself and a panther locked
in battle Okoye rescues Ross from captivity making
him a fugitive from the American government and
leaving Okoye in her Midnight Angel suit finally
with some headgear that she's comfortable in the
final scene brings her into a beach in Haiti where
she finally allows herself to burn her funeral
garments she closed her eyes and meditates and
she flashes back to the images of t'challa from
the 2018 film when he walked down the hallway
to her lab and gave his sister their handshake
when she placed his necklace suit on him after
he resurrected the first time he walked into
the the throne room is King and she finally
breathes to let go of her brother she and we
are lulled by Rihanna's lift me up the lyrics
of which become Sheree's prayer to her brother
Lift Me Up Hold Me Down hold me close safe and
sound now burning in a hopeless dream Echoes the
fire of the despair that she felt in her nightmare
with Kilmer in the second verse that part becomes
drowning in an Endless Sea a contrast to Fire and
Water there but both represent killmonger and no
more dragging shuri down into violence which is
why the chorus comes back to the prayer of lift
me up and in the post-credits scene her prayers
are answered exactly you see that's like when we
were talking about in the live stream I was saying
that like I think it's a great intermission song
for right after the end credits and before the
what the post-credits is it's like the perfect in
between for it and I think it's one of the best
closing credit songs the mcu's ever had yeah songs
you know they're all songs but they're you know
like with lyrics and stuff that are poignant and
meaningful and reflective of the film and I think
it's a perfectly apt song for it oh yeah well and
the way the first movie had such a Big Splash with
like we've got this curated soundtrack and Marvel
doesn't do yeah like spot music soundtrack scores
usually yeah it's like there's not a lot of songs
Amalgamated from artists and this felt like a way
to you know continue that tradition but also
focus it in on one specific piece and in the
post-credits scene her prayers are answered
Nakia introduces Sherry to her nephew to Saint
Sherry says the name to Saint carries a history
referring to to Saint the Overture sorry if I
mispronounced that my prince sucks but this
guy was awesome called the black Napoleon
the father of Haiti who in 1791 led a successful
slave revolt against the French and one Haitian
Independence I think what I love most about this
line is that it signals sure he has through her
wakandan Outreach centers that she built with
t'challa has begun to learn more black history
from outside wakanda and has begun to reconnect
with that lost tribe that killmonger fought for
I mean I don't know sure he's pretty smart maybe
she already knew this stuff but it did seem like
in the 2018 film all she really seemed to know
about the outside world was like Disneyland and
Back to the Future too Saint reveals that his
real name is t'challa son of King t'challa he
would be no more than six or seven years old so we
would need a bit of a time job before we see any
real superhero action from this kid even if you
were to join a group like the Young Avengers but
a new t'challa lives he has his whole life ahead
of him and he knows where he comes from and who
his baba was the Black Panther is not a burden
sure you must carry alone anymore her brother
is gone but wakanda is forever follow me on Tick
Tock wakanda forever forever rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye epic breakdown
man very beautiful very well done beautifully done
my God four and a half of that black panther today
for us yep longer than the movie itself like
just when I thought I couldn't appreciate the
movie more here comes Voss that's beautiful thank
you for putting that together new rock stars team
you guys did an excellent excellent job guys
subscribe leave a like thanks for the pain
Daniel gallacher Daniel happy belated
birthday it was your birthday just a
couple of days ago Dude so I hope it was a
good one we are honoring our patrons right
now who have been the most loyal to us over
the years and you've been a patron of ours
for 51 months that is a very obnoxiously
long time to not have illegally shipped
us things from the pharmacy that you work
at what is your deal Manny's Danny so much
[Music] and but 51 months is a very long time
so I know in Scotland you guys didn't celebrate
Thanksgiving because you're not American meaning
you're not cool but regardless uh I wanted to say
thank you for being just as awesome as you are
and as um gracious as you have been this entire
time and it's it's an absolute joy to have you
in our lives so wish you a Merry Christmas I
hope you have a wonderful 2023 and uh is this
you in the thumbnail or is that your girlfriend
zoom in I think this is his girlfriend because
he's been like talking nuts no that's Daniel
but you are beautiful enough you know what it
is the stuff in the background made it look
like long hair yeah yeah all right and the and
the yeah the the bits on your shirt almost yeah
this is a hot white girlfriend yeah but you're
just a hot hot white person a new hot white
man instead yeah you're the real Everett Ross of
the real rejects Nation Daniel Gallagher foreign